I just had a business in covert until I
was something lost I wanted to know you
were in my same situation right now and
you even have like this platform what
would you do I would buy and sell
something I actually am interested in I
was really interested in the mask and
stuff like that no you were interested
in The Mask because you saw the
opportunities let me say it one more
time buy and sell something you're
actually interested in because you knew
the answer to the last part don't give a
[__] about masks you saw the money
opportunity that's good that's called
being an entrepreneur so if you [__]
with sneakers or sports or whatever the
[__] I really [__] with wine I really
[__] with marketing you will never build
a massive platform unless the thing you
do is [__] love because the money
part it's like [__] sugar everybody
follows money which has spikes but they
make